we've got the sound now okay I probably
don't have to start again a bit
and they painted a picture of the future
which was full of flying cars and
intelligent robots well actually that
futures arriving a friend of mine
Sebastian Thrun is CEO of a company
Kittyhawk there's building flying cars
and every day you open the newspaper you
read about some new advance that is
being made in artificial intelligence
that we can beat the best go player on
the planet we can win at the game show
Jeopardy we can read mammograms better
than human doctors and so lots of people
are starting to ask well where is this
all going to end and some people are
getting a little worried so I'm here to
try and focus your worries on the right
things because unfortunately lots of the
worries that people have seem to come
straight out of Hollywood and they're
probably not the things you should be
worrying about and some very small
people Stephen Hawkins have said some
rather strong statements about the fact
we should be worrying about the
development of artificial intelligence
and that was backed up by Elon Musk
someone who knows something about
disruptive technologies he's been
disrupting banking with PayPal with cars
with Tesla and space travel with SpaceX
and he said that AI is potentially the
biggest existential threat that
threatens our very existence
Bill Gates back him up said I agree with
Stephen Hawking's and and Elon Musk and
then there was a New York Times
bestseller written by Nick Bostrom a
philosopher at Oxford saying hey is
going to be a big deal in fact it could
be the most consequential thing that we
ever do I mean there's an argument as
soon as we've invented AI that's the
last thing we ever need to invent
because the AI can start doing the
invention itself so with some very small
people saying things like this it's not
surprising that maybe you are starting
to get a little worried should we fear
what Nick Bostrom er said
for intelligence should it should it be
potentially the biggest existential
threat well I want you all to sleep
soundly tonight we are still a very very
long way away from building intelligence
that matches our own human brain is the
most complex system we know of in the
universe by orders of magnitude
nothing approaches the billions of
neurons the trillions of connections to
him brain has and whilst we can build
systems that do impressive things the
play go very well they are still idiot
savants they're very good at one task
nothing approaches the breadth of
ability of the human brain our ability
to be dropped into a new situation
without any training and to start doing
something useful the systems we build do
one task we work hard we they could do
that one task well they could often do
it better than us humans but they are
incredibly brittle you try and give them
some other task and they'll break I'll
forego that program that beat Lisa dull
one of the best go players on the planet
and recently beat beat fail easy the
Chinese go master that can only play go
even to get it to play chess would take
person months or person years of efforts
to reprogram it it's not going to wake
up in the morning and say you know what
you humans you're no good at go I'm
going to make some money at online poker
and there's no chance in hell is going
to wake up and say you know humans
you're no good at running a planet I'm
going to take over and do a better job
it's not in his code it's only ever
going to play go in fact it doesn't even
know it's playing go all it knows is
there's this number the probability that
is likely to win this match of go and
it's trying to maximize this number and
if you change going us in to say what
you might call Gila go where the game is
not to command as much territory but to
lose a much territory it would have to
start from scratch
whereas I could give that to any go
master they could start playing kill ago
instantly so also one of the things that
people have is this idea of the
technological singularity that some
point will build machines they'll be so
smart that they'll be able to improve
themselves they'll be able to redesign
themselves those machines will redesign
themselves and this is going to be some
tipping point this this is the
technological singularity this is one
reason that what some people so worried
Nick Bostrom is so worried about about
super intelligence it's going to happen
very quickly what's something else I
want to reassure you is that in all
probability it's not going to happen
very quickly it's not going to happen
overnight we don't know how to build
machines that can recursively self
improve themselves likely we're going to
build machines that are intelligent
maybe even more intelligent I hope
pointer than us but by the hard way the
way that we've always done things in the
past by our own sweat and engineering
it's not going to happen overnight it's
not going to happen by some amazing
ability of the machines to snowball away
with their intelligence it's going to
take a long time we could have plenty of
time 50 hundred even more years to
prepare for that moment but machines are
more intelligent than us and I'm pretty
sure we'll get there hopefully in my
lifetime but maybe not so if that's not
the Odin thing what we should be
worrying about I actually want to
persuade you there are some really
pressing problems today not to do with
super intelligence to do with AI and to
do with the way the technology is
invading our lives invading our society
that we you have to wake up and start
thinking about so what are those
problems well the first thing I want to
assure you is because well I'm a
professor AI want to show you that it's
not AI that you have to worry about it's
mostly autonomy the fact that we're
giving machines the ability to act in
the world and that ability to act means
that they may have to make for example
life-or-death decisions and we've seen
that today with autonomous cars
economist car will be driving down the
road and it will come across some
situation they will have to make a life
changing
decision and that's the problem that's
that's the moral challenge that we face
today so we're giving machines the
ability to act it's not that they're a
that's not that they're artificially
intelligent it's the fact that they're
autonomous that's the pros the ethical
challenge and in fact the smarter they
are the less challenges you have the
better the decisions they'll be making
and I'm much more worried today about
the fact that we're giving autonomy to
stupid AI machines but don't know how
how to act properly but don't know how
to make those proper ethical choices
that will be discriminating we'll come
to some of these issues in a second so
it's stupid AI that I'm worried about
today not smart AI and if we go to that
example of autonomous cars I'd like to
point out there is an absolute moral
imperative to do that there's a moral
imperative to develop autonomous cars a
million people will die on the roads of
the planet this year in road traffic
accidents thirty thousand people in the
United States it's a five or six
thousand people I believe in Germany
that's a plane crash happening every day
a fully loaded plane crashing every day
in car accidents ninety five percent of
which are caused by the idiot driving
them and as soon as we can get the
idiots out of the driving wheel replace
it by a computer which is going to be
much more reliable but safer our roads
going to be we're terrible drivers we
drive drunk
we drive distracted we drive tired we
drive while we're texting we're not
supposed to but we do we make lots and
lots of mistakes mistakes that computers
well mistake they won't be tired they
won't be drunk they won't be texting
there'll be focus 100% on driving and
they'll be eventually much better
drivers than any of us could ever be so
there's a real moral imperative that we
develop the technology it will give
mobility for the first time to the
elderly
to the young to the disabled there will
be vast parts of our society will be
transformed our cities will be opened up
there no longer be parking spaces for
cars the cars will go off and do useful
things they won't have to sit there
waiting for you to be finished they can
go off and earn you money as nuba taxi
they will free up our cities there was a
study done for the city of Lisbon it was
estimated that if you had autonomous
cars you could provide the same
transport needs with one-tenth of the
cars imagine how that's going to
transform our cityscape it's going to
change completely the way we interact
the way we work so that's going to be a
great benefit to society but we just got
to make sure that we get there in the
right place and we will get there we
will get two cars with a much safer
autonomous cars that much safer the
mouse Sweden has a 2020 target to have
zero road deaths by 2020 and there's a
fantastic graph I recommend you go and
look it up on the Internet
showing the road deaths against years
it's a straight line going down and it's
going to hit the zero axis by about 2020
but so far they've had all the cheap
gains they've redesigned the roads that
may put airbags in cars they've made
cars much safer but to get down to zero
the only way that they can get down to
zero is to remove the error full human
from the loop replace that by a computer
so there's a real moral imperative to
get there and in fact you can go out and
buy a car today you could buy yourself a
Tesla and at least on the highway it
will drive autonomously around town
urban driving is a little more challenge
on the highway cars all going in the
same direction there aren't round too
many roundabouts or intersections to
worry about so much even easier tasks to
program a computer to drive autonomously
down the highway urban driving is good
more of a challenge there's still a few
years before we'll have cracked urban
driving but we will crack urban driving
but that's not without its risk and this
is one of the things I think we should
start worrying about the
is Joshua Browns teszler Joshua Brown
has gone down in history books as the
first pillar person killed by his
autonomous car in Florida last May last
year he was driving down the highway and
his you know autonomous mode autopilot
motors Tesla call it and his Tesla drove
into a truck that was turning across the
path that was in the Sun his Tesla
didn't see the truck he wasn't paying
attention by all accounts he was
actually watching a Harry Potter movie
don't watch a Harry Potter movie when
you're sitting in your Tesla he
shouldn't have been watching Harry
Potter mover but he was I mean when
you're sitting in on solomon's car not
having to do much for a while it's easy
to be distracted and it killed him he
was instantly killed 70 miles an hour as
the tesla drove into the truck of course
this was bad news for Tesla the share
price didn't do very well
Tesla were a bit upset about the bad
publicity this good so they put out a
press release about how someone's life
was saved when they had a heart attack
or a stroke or some medical emergency
and their Tesla drove them autonomously
to the hospital where they were able to
be rescued by the doctors at this point
I put my head in my hands and shook it
in disbelief because what is being
happening here is that Public Safety is
deciding by who has the best press
release this is not the responsible way
to develop a technology and we're
letting our governments get away
literally with murder if I said to you
there's a drug company it's testing its
products on the public pretty much
without any special permission knowing
that it's going to kill people you'd say
well well how are they allowed to get
away with that surely there are laws
against that you can't test your product
on the public without their approval
without ethics consent or anything like
this
yet that's what we let Silicon Valley
Tesla has no permission from the public
no ethics approvals to test its product
update his product overnight and we are
letting our governments allow this to
happen this word drug company would not
happen another feature of this is well
this is great the Silicon Valley of way
of developing products pushing the PETA
product ad under the public getting
rapid feedback on your product and
developing it in public that works when
it's a spreadsheet that works when it's
a word processor no one's life is at
stake here people's lives are at stake
and sometime in the next year it's not
going to be a Tesla driver that's killed
it's going to be a pedestrian it's going
to be a cyclist it's going to be someone
that you might know someone who never
gave consent so whilst this product
development cycle works when we were
developing spreadsheets it's very
unclear to me that that's the way we
should be developing products like
autonomous cars where people's lives are
at stake the endpoint of course 0 Road s
is going to be a fantastic one we just
got to worry how we get there we've got
a demand that we get there in a suitably
stringent way and just one third a
little observation here
Tesla drive their cars with cameras and
radar
there's no lidar so why does this thing
this looks like it normally looks like a
rotating ice cream cone that sits on the
top of say the Google autonomous car
rotates around it's the light form of
radar sends out the light and laser beam
rotates around gives you distance very
accurately whatever the weather two
objects around you Tesla doesn't have
lidar my friends who build autonomous
cars would never attempt to build an
autonomous car without lighter Tesla
have said the cars their something today
the hard way they're selling today will
be fully autonomous it's just a matter
of them getting the program right in a
couple of years time but your toes
you buy today has all the hardware in it
you need to have fully autonomous cars
the only reason it doesn't have laser
because today lidar is too expensive it
will add tens of thousands of dollars to
the cost of a Tesla Tesla don't think
they can sell you cars that expensively
but they're prepared to let those cars
drive for the autonomously whilst my
colleagues academics building autonomous
cars would never attempt to try and
build a car but doesn't have that really
useful sensor is it right the Tesla is
allowed to make that sort of decision
I'm not sure things that I think we as
the public should be demanding ok that's
one thing to worry about something else
to worry about I'm not going to talk too
much about this one I'm happy to talk in
the Q&A about this which is algorithm
some of them quite stupid are really
impacting our political debate you've
seen this a brexit you've seen this in
the Trump election the Twittersphere
now has more computer voices more
Twitter BOTS in it than human voices
Trump had more supporters who were
computers than were people how are we
going to have a sensible political
debate when human voices are drowned out
by computer voices another worrying
aspect of algorithms onto the political
debate is what companies like Cambridge
analytic are doing they had a very
carefully targeted campaign using your
Facebook Likes to target the swing
voters it's becoming a algorithm race
between the political parties who they
can target with with with very
controversial adverts is this the way
that we want our political debate to be
discussed or do we want people to be
well-informed not not filled with fake
news that our algorithms are giving us
these are really challenging questions
that we have to start thinking about
today and they're really impacting our
lives another aspect of algorithms that
I do want to spend a little more time on
is this idea of algorithmic
discrimination that we're starting to
give algorithms the ability to act
what's under me and then making
decisions the impact upon our lives that
may
be discriminatory but maybe denying us
credit maybe actually not giving us that
job or in the case in the United States
of the compass program depriving people
of their liberty so the compass program
is used in 20 of the 52 United States to
decide to help judges decide probation
conditions when to release people from
jail it's a program machine learning
program that's designed to predict the
probability that a violent criminal riaf
end well there's nothing in itself wrong
with writing a machine learning program
to make a prediction of whether a
violent criminal is going to reoffended
lots of good things with this you could
use this for example to decide where to
spend limited probationary services how
to spend best money how to support
people when they come out of jail who
are most likely to fall off this the
straight and narrow that would be a
pretty good thing to do that would make
society a safer place hope those people
get back into society
that's not how it's being used it's
being used to decide who gets locked up
and who doesn't now you're probably
thinking well that's starting to sound a
bit morally suspect and now here's the
kicker the kicker is the program is
racially biased it's more likely to
predict that black people were
reoffending will and it's more likely to
predict that why people will not
reoffending will the net effect is that
black people are being locked up because
of a buggy program and white people are
being released into society perhaps
dangerously so because of a buggy
program and now this point you must be
thinking then while this is sounding
very morally dubious right now there's
no reason why if we tried harder we
couldn't remove that discrimination from
the program when we could remove the
discrimination so it more accurately
predicted well actually
perhaps humans did they better see that
the probability that people going to
reoffended still be left with this moral
question and I think this is a really
profound one that we as a society must
start asking us these are sort of
decisions we should be giving to
machines even if they're the correct
decisions
isn't it something that we should just
leave to humans
the most important decisions in our
society we typically give to a jury of
our peers we don't I think once a give
them we don't want to wake up in a world
where we say wait a second we've loved
these people up because of what a
program has said I don't want to wake up
in a world like that I suspect many of
you don't want to wake up in a world
like that and there's another real risk
which is that we'll just bake in all of
the prejudices that we have today these
programs these machine learning programs
they don't explain themselves yet today
we're still working on that we don't
really have a good understanding of how
they work the fact that they work well
is great but we don't really understand
how they work and if we train them on
existing data this is part of the
problem with the compass program they'll
bake in all of the prejudices maybe
there were more black people in prison
because police officers I dread to say
it we're a little racially biased judges
jurors might have been a bit racially
biased and if we allow machine learning
to train on that historical data we'll
bake in those biases and we'll continue
to perpetuate this racism throughout
society now we'll wake up in a world in
20 years time where many of the
hard-fought rights of racial
discrimination age discrimination sex
discrimination will have been lost
because we've given them over to
programs programs that can't explain
themselves okay another thing we think
we should worry about technological
unemployment will AI will our tokens on
automation end many jobs or even all
jobs
okay now put your hand up if you've got
an odds birthday always think I should
tell you what an odd birthday it seems
but some people obviously got our
birthdays what
born on an odd-numbered day of the month
I was born on the 11th of April 11 is
not number come on I know it's half the
room it's half the room half the room I
know that okay good good you keep you
end up because you want to have good
kids right you're the good lucky people
right you're the lucky people I'm
looking all the lucky people right
because you're someone in twenty years
time it's going to have a job if you
believe the chief economist of the Bank
of England someone you hope know
something about jobs and the employment
prospects November the 13th two years
ago he said fortunate there was a very
sad news story breaking Paris that day
might have distract you he wins on the
record that day is saying fifty percent
of jobs in the UK are under threat from
automation in the next couple of decades
fifty percent of jobs that's why you'll
be old people that's why you're the
lucky people right he is not the only
prediction most of these predictions can
be traced back to a very influential
report that came out of the University
of Oxford 2013 that came up with this
number that forty-seven percent of jobs
in the United States are risk for
automation in the next two decades now
ironically this job of predicting the
number of jobs to be automated was
actually automated they used machine
learning program to do the prediction
and so they save themselves to work you
can't believe this number
I've looked closely at the data some of
the data is rubbish one of the
predictions is that bicycle repair
person is going to be automated in the
next two decades there's zero chance the
bicycle repair person is going to be
automate it so difficult tricky job it's
low paid job and it's a social job I'm a
friend of mine runs a bike shop I know
at the point of repairing bikes is just
to have people hang out there discuss
bike routes talk about politics drink
coffee
it's not about repairing bikes right
it's not a job you're going to replace
by a robot anytime soon right but
nevertheless even I asked I did a survey
of 300 of my colleagues working in AI
they came up with a number it's not a
half of all jobs the third they came up
with a number but a third of all jobs
are at risk of automation significant
number of jobs at risk of automation of
course
every technology creates new jobs as
well as destroying jobs well create
there's lots of new jobs that will be
created jobs that we have no idea what
they are today because they involve
technologies that are going to be
invented in 10 years time but what we
don't know and there's complete
uncertainty about this is one more jobs
be created and destroyed historically
that's been true ever since the
Industrial Revolution we've created more
jobs than we've destroyed with
technology the planet has more people on
it today employed than ever before and
unemployment levels are historical low
levels so we've created jobs jobs
disappeared in the forms most of the
workforce was out farming before the
Industrial ushion we created lots of new
jobs and offices and factories that have
absorbed all those people and we might
spread her off because of it but last
time was different last time was
different because we replace manual
labor but we still had all the cognitive
things we could do and there's this real
question this time well what's left for
us this should be very apparent to uber
drivers now uber driver is one of the
newest jobs on the planet in September
last year uber started trialing
autonomous taxes in Pittsburgh and then
quickly afterwards in San Francisco uber
drivers should have realized their job
is going to be automated very soon
ironically this newest job on the planet
is likely one of the shortest live jobs
on the planet the most expensive thing
in an uber taxi is the driver at the
front
uber won a scale like every other
internet business the only way they can
do that if they can get rid of the
humans and of course every great
benefits the price of an uber taxi for
all of us is going to plummet it's going
to be as cheap to take an uber is to
take a bus so for most of us it's going
to be a great advantage but if you're an
uber driver it's not that job is going
to disappear no one's going to be
willing to pay that amount of money to
be taken around in an uber taxi equally
if your truck driver it's going to be
much cheaper
have autonomous trucks their work also
is working on autonomous trucks now so
if lots of jobs are going to change
disappear if I was creating the planet
at this point in time and have this
disruption brought around brought around
by technology I wouldn't do a cup of
other things that are happening to the
planet today I wouldn't throw into the
mix the global financial crisis because
the global financial crisis is going to
go on in fact this I suspect is never
going to end with in this new type of
economics where you just put money right
we just all have to pretend but that's
how money works and then the planet
would survive right it's a bit like the
emperor's clothes we just have to
pretend and it will keep on going like
that we wouldn't throw in also into the
mix global China collect global climate
change that's going to stress the planet
even further and cause even more
economic stress the fact that the
population is increasing greatly and
aging again other things with the stress
in our plans if you're trying to create
the environment for a good transition
with technology you wouldn't put all
these other things the stresses into the
planet at the same time oh I'm a global
refugee problem right you know having
this millions of people being displaced
and stress stressing our different
societies so there's lots of things that
are challenging us as well as the
technological change and there's some
very wiring trends this is a you can
find many grass go and read Thomas
Pickett is capital in the 21st century
look at some of the graphs you can find
this is one of the more wiring graphs
this is how productivity and employment
has changed the last 50 70 years since
the Second World War and you see this
wonderful sort of exponential increase
in productivity productivity is the
orange line technology has brought us
great increases in productivity in GDP
in our prosperity in all the quality of
our lives we live much better lives than
our grandparents did that's been great
constant growth the thing that we've
restrained technology is largely
delivered
the brownish line is employment levels
this is employment in the United States
that you see similar things if you look
at employment in Germany or any of the
Western European countries and you see
employment has tracked productivity as
our economies has grown and become more
prosperous with far more ways of
employing people so that's been great
people have the product employment has
gone up until the dot-com crash 2000 and
there's this worrying disconnect data is
noisy but it looks like it's
disconnecting that we're continuing to
see productivity growth through
automation and various other things but
employment and staggered in fact in
certain some census is slightly fallen
there are other graphs you can see
another thing that's very worrying is
this thing that's called hollowing out
of the middle which is we look at the
distribution of the workforce between
low skilled middle skills and high
skilled occupations that you see that 30
years 40 years ago the 59% of us were in
middle skilled occupations the sort of
things you went to university to be a
lawyer a journalist accountant these
sorts of jobs and those sorts of jobs
are disappearing that's now forty five
percent of those jobs and what we're
seeing is more people are being employed
as baristas and in fast food shops and
that low skilled occupations are
increasing so these are very worrying
trends now I'm not really I'm a
technologist not an economist so I think
we're going to have to discuss some
significant structural changes to our
society but what can you do as a person
so I can give you at least personal
advice by by thinking about what can the
technology do what can the technology
not do right and so I have for you a
triangle a triangle of opportunity you
want to be one of the corners of this
triangle one of the three corners of the
triangle don't find yourself in the
middle of the triangle where your job
will be automated okay so what the top
of the tide the apex of the triangle
well that's the job for everyone in this
room which is be someone inventing the
future you are all geeks like me
you are perfectly happy coding writing
the programs developing the hardware
changing the future be someone riding
that wave of Technology so we're pretty
safe what about your friends okay not
everyone of course is technically minded
not everyone wants to be a geek that's
good because there's two other corners
to the triangle the second corner of the
triangle is for people with good people
skills social intelligence emotional
intelligence computers have none of that
and they're a really important part of
our lives we are social animals there's
immense opportunities and jobs that
involve interacting with people jobs in
sales jobs in psychology being a CEO is
actually just the job for the person
with the best emotional intelligence in
the room right
managing people looking after people
interacting with people all those sorts
of jobs well computers are not good at
that and we won't want to interact with
computers wouldn't want to interact with
people with people people okay and the
third corner of the triangle the final
quarter is for the artistic in the
artisan computer still are not very
creative we're working on that we'll
hopefully get there one day but still
today they're not very creative and
there's lots of things that they're
creatively challenged in we are much
more creative as humans as well with
increasingly value things made with the
human hand things that the machine made
will be cheap from plentiful the things
that were man-made artisan bread
handmade beer novels film all these
sorts of things music will appreciate
the human element that went into it the
human suffering that they describe the
human pleasure and pain and love these
sorts of things will appreciate those
things and if we believe economists our
economies will adjust to pay for this
right the market will adjust to make
those things more valuable and if you
look at hipster culture today you see
that already okay but there's a bigger
societal question I'm not going to spend
time on that we can pass through this in
the Q&A we will have to think about how
do we adjust the society so that those
put out of work
are gainfully employed are filled
prosperous and useful to society well we
have to go to universal basic income
negative tax rates well we have to find
some way of supporting people like this
education will have to become a lifelong
activity we made really big changes to
our society in the industrial ushion we
introduced universal education the
welfare system pension systems union
child labor laws we made some big
structural changes last time so the AI
revolution will have to think about some
really big changes and I want to finish
with one last thing I want you to worry
about which is about how AI is going to
change warfare and what we should be
doing about that today when I talk about
a.m. warfare people always think about
Terminator whenever I talk about AI in
the media that the media put up a
picture of terminators that here's the
picture of terminator ok that's not what
we have to worry about and again it's
not a is autonomy two years ago almost
to the day I got a thousand of my
colleagues for leading experts in AI on
robotics to sign an open letter that we
released at the start of the third of
the main international AI conference of
the year in Buddhist areas calling upon
the UN to put a ban on autonomous
weapons warning that there was going to
be an arms race and that the endpoint
was not a good one the letter was signed
by people like Steven Hawkins and Elon
Musk people that we mentioned earlier
but what was more important to me was
that all of my colleagues sign a letter
people who understand the technology I
think that's the most significant part
of their letter it captured headlines
around the world it appeared on the BBC
CNN Sky News New York Times The Guardian
everywhere covered this story at the
time we warned that there was going to
be an arms race and I'm sorry to say in
the two years since that letter came out
there has been already the beginnings of
an arms race you can see videos on
YouTube of the sorts of technologies
being prototype by the militaries this
is british aerospace systems autonomous
drone the trainer's frightening-looking
thing that can fly across continents
completely autonomously
in every theater this is the air we go
to the sea
heeey this is the US Navy's first
autonomous ship the sea Shepherd sea
hunter which was launched about a year
ago they're now saying they're going to
put weapons on this thing it's not just
going to be a mine clearer this is the
land we've got the Russian MLK 25 on
autonomous tank and under the sea here
we've got Boeing's autonomous submarine
that can't reverse the Pacific
completely autonomously there's an arms
race to develop these technologies the
end point is not going to be a very good
one for society for the planet they will
be weapons of terror you only have to
see pictures of these swarms of drones
to realize how terror for these weapons
will be if you think we have a problem
with refugees in Syria today fleeing
series today you wait to the civilian
population has a swarm of these drones
mass-produced printed with 3d printers
at cheap cost by despots and terrorist
organizations you will see a real
refugee problem then these will be real
weapons of terror they will be weapons
of mass destruction previously if you
wanted to commit atrocities you had to
persuade an army of people to follow
your evil way in the future you will
need one programmer
this will industrialized warfare to a
scale that we've never seen before it's
being being called rightly so the third
revolution in warfare first revolution
being the invention of gunpowder by the
Chinese the second revolution being the
invention of nuclear bombs by the by the
US ways that were step changes in the
speed and efficiency with which we can
kill the other side this will be another
step change in the speed and efficiency
where you can kill the other side and
that's why thousands of my colleagues
signed that letter with myself saying
for the UN let's discuss seriously
putting a ban on this technology every
now and again we've come together as a
society as a planet and said actually
the world would be a better place not to
have chemical weapons not to have
biological weapons not to have lining
lasers not to have anti-personnel mines
let's decide that this is that this is a
technology that should be used for good
aims like building autonomous cars and
not for Bad ends
it will be terribly destabilizing as I
said once terrorists and road nations
like North Korea get their hands on this
as a technology it will completely upset
the very delicate balance of power we
already have today and there is an arms
race these are Boston Dynamics latest
toys they're robots Atlas on the
left-hand side there's a terrifying
video on YouTube you can see this guy
walking through a snowy forest being
pushed over I used to say you know
terminators all that don't worry that's
at least a hundred years away look at
this guy so I think maybe actually I can
have to say these 50 years away it's
starting to look like Hollywood says and
the end point is going to be like
Hollywood the Hollywood's pretty good at
predicting the future the end point will
be pretty much like what Hollywood says
but before we get to the end point
people are going to be giving stupid AI
the ability to make life with their
decisions this could be making lots of
mistakes now will I discuss this issue
it's nice to point out to people that
it's not completely black away there are
arguments for and against and I just
want to go over the five most common
arguments I get put against the idea of
banning autonomous weapons or killer
robots there's the media like to call
them the first one the the first
objection people say well women Tobey
robots are going to be more efficient
actually I think why we should ban them
they will be more efficient they won't
least to begin with for the first few
decades be more effective they won't be
able to discriminate between civilian
and combatants in the fog of war they
won't be able to apply international
humanitarian law that legally obliged to
do when you build systems they have to
follow they have to discriminate they
have to reply force that's proportional
to the threat posed we don't know how to
build robots like that they'll be making
lots of mistakes when the drone papers
were released in November last year it
was revealed that nine out of ten of the
people being killed by Predator drones
above the skies of Afghanistan in Iraq
were not the intended target that's why
you've still got a human in the loop you
could take the human out of the loop
UK's Ministry of Defense said they could
do that today if they wanted to replace
that human who's making them a final
decision with the Predator drone by a
computer program the small technical
leap we as technologists our target
would be to make nine out of ten
mistakes that will be our aspiration
will be making far more mistakes the
second objection I hear is what robots
can be more ethical now actually this is
the most interesting at least
philosophically the most interesting
objection but war is a terrible thing
atrocities get committed in in the
process of war terrible things happen in
war and that's true and then if we have
programs to do these things well there
follow precise program they won't break
out of those programs they'll follow
those the letter of the program but the
problems are there's two problems with
this argument the first problem is well
we don't know how to write those
programs we don't may today how to write
programs to behave ethically we're
working on that problem it's a couple of
decades away pass before we know how to
build programs that could behave
appropriately ethically we'll need to
solve this problem we're new to solve it
because we'll have autonomous cars
driving down the road but we'll need to
make ethical decisions about whether to
write run into a pedestrian that stepped
into the road or run into a brick wall
but we don't know how to build ethical
programs today and even when we do in a
decade or two decades or however long it
takes us to work out this problem we're
still left with a challenge which is
every program we know how to build can
be hacked and so these programs will be
hacks there are bad people out there who
will have no qualms about turning off
any ethical over-over guards that we
have on these programs so even if we
know how to build ethical robots they'll
be turned off behave we've made to
behave in unethical ways third
objectives what blank frame words can
just kind of fight robots now that's a
terribly naive objection right there's
not a separate part of the world you
know the battlefield side battles over
here please
battles are fought in towns and cities
amongst civilian pop
and it's innocent women children and
civilians that get caught in the
crossfire and even if we could agree to
those rules the other side in these
asymmetric context that we now fight is
not going to agree fair was the case we
wouldn't need any weapons we could just
say we'll decide it with a game of chess
let's not how wars are fought wars are
fought by being terrible
and then the final objections well but
weapon bans don't work well again
history contradicts you there are a
number of successful weapon bans for
biological weapons for chemical weapons
anti blinding lasers for anti-personnel
mines even the nuclear non-proliferation
treaty which is limited to a large
extent the use of these technologies and
so my hope is that we can actually get
people like the United Nations on board
on these ideas if there's enough moral
pressure from people like you that we do
this the UN is I'm pleased to say moving
slowly well for them they're saying
they're moving in lightning speed for me
they're moving slowly because there
isn't much time to deal deal with this
but anyway precipitated in part by that
open letter last year's last December
when I spoke at the UN they decided to
move to formal talks after three years
of informal talks they have moved to
formal talks they form what's called a
group of governmental experts at the
main disarmament treaty the conventional
certain conventional weapons and in
November this year they will start the
very first formal talks on this topic
and hopefully with moral pressure from
society and from elsewhere they'll
decide to ban this sort of technology so
just to wrap up there's much of it much
for you to worry about it's not many of
the things that Hollywood says it's
about stupid AI not smart AI autonomous
cars technological environment algorithm
advice there's a whole bunch of things
I've given you to worry about now but I
do want you to remember and perhaps
longer term super does but I do want you
to remember all the good things I
mentioned all the challenges the face
society today but the only hope we have
actually to solve most of these
challenges is to invest in technology
the last 50 years or prosperity of
growth in fact that we live better life
than our grandparents has come about by
technology most of it because of
information technology because of
computing and if we're going to attack
with some of these problems in the next
50 years we only have one hand of cards
to play today
and that's to invest in the technology
it's about the only solution we have for
climate change for the financial crisis
for helping deal with things like the
refugee problem and for dealing with
with the prosperity the technological
change will bring so we need to invest
but we need to think about the decisions
we need to make some people think the
future is something that you have to
react to as opposed to it's the future
is decided by the decisions we make
today and we start to make those
decisions now and so just to finish I
believe we're going to have time for
some questions before before the end if
you want to find out more I've got a
book that's coming out later this month
you can pre-order it on Amazon it's
called it's alive
artificial intelligence from the logic
piano to killer robots good thank you
very much and happy to take questions
I believe there's a microphone sir you
insinuated that police officers and
probably the US justice system were
discriminatory even racist
what is your data to back that up I
suggested that there's a possibility
that it might be racist I'm not the only
one who's made this observation you only
have to look at the number of black
people on death row which is
disproportionate to the population to
see that maybe or you're discriminating
against poverty more than you are
against well yeah the statistics right
now and blacks are 15% of the population
but they commit more than 50% of the
murders so maybe if you correct well
they commit a few percent of the murders
that we prosecute and that we find the
murder for they it's not clear that that
you're locking up the right people that
we're necessarily finding the right
people right so you think they are
undiscovered murders in their thousands
in the US or maybe you haven't looked at
the data enough to make these statements
I it's not important to the argument
whether whether whether the system is is
biased or not we know for example that
that there is a real sex sex bias in you
know wages today in the United States
and in Germany and most Western
countries women are women unless more
paid the men there's good statistics on
that if we then use algorithms to hire
people and we base it on historical data
we will bake in those biases well Ron
which I love to you at the time but
thank you the the challenge here is that
we have biases some of which we may know
about some of which we may not know
about and if we just train on existing
historical data we will just inherit
those biases so you've got to be very
careful what you do and know
what what what is in your data and
whether your data contains any biases
that you want to eliminate good question
here okay
hi right the back my question is about
bias as well it's a bit more of a
technical question so the when we're
talking about courts or talking about
credits or talking about any of the
decisions that we make based on rules
this person should be locked up this
person shouldn't we're talking about a
problem in AI having bias
I think everyone's accepted that the
human beings have those biases as well
there were a few publications by Google
recently trying to define what unwanted
bias was where the population a and B
should have either the same acceptance
rate or a lock-up rate or should have
the same correct lock operate or correct
acceptance rate how do you define
discrimination can you try and make a
hard definition of what discrimination
should room should mean so that's a
great question we don't know right so
we're only starting to have this
conversation and part of it is a
technical question which is you know so
if we can give a formal - inner
definition of fairness of bias then we
can try and define the right an
algorithm that will respect that
property but we don't actually know yet
what those properties are I think this
is going to be the golden age of
philosophy the philosophy and ethics
have got lost to the last 100 years in
thinking about the philosophy of
language and all of this unuseful stuff
and now we're going to have to wake up
because we're writing programs to carry
those decisions in our society we're
gonna have to work out precisely what we
mean to be unbiased we don't know if we
just starting the journey of working out
what that is and that's suppose the
technical question some of the things
that Google and my colleagues and
machine learning are thinking about but
also a societal question we have to work
out as a society what it means to be
unbiased in a precise enough way that we
can write a program to do that and we're
only beginning to have these
conversation so we're only the
challenges that we're already giving
machines
the right to make these sorts of
decisions yet we haven't worked out what
we want for these decisions it will I
think be a fantastic age to be a
philosopher because for once you'll be
forced to make really concrete decisions
that we can write in code I've actually
said every cup every tech company is
going to have a CPO a chief
philosophical officer who's going to
worry about this issue is going to think
hard about these issues and engage in
this discussion that we as a society
have to have but what does it mean for a
program to be unbiased hello at the
beginning of your talk you mentioned
Isaac Asimov and I also really like his
books and a very central theme in his a
robot series is the tree laws of
robotics which directly links to what
you're saying about ethics so in your
opinion are we even close to having
something that looks like the Three Laws
of Robotics for AI and like what would
it take to get there and is it even
possible or even desirable that's a
lovely question and yeah we we need to
solve this problem we're going to have
machines acting in our world with the
ability to make life-or-death decisions
as those autonomous cars really starting
to do we need them to behave to have
values that are line with the ones that
the line with our society that make our
lives better not worse so we need to
solve this problem we don't know how to
solve the problem most of our guys are
most stories about his laws of robotics
or about the problems with his laws and
about how it's difficult to interpret
the laws and then there was a zeroth
losses actually so there became four
laws I'm quite a fan of I J Goode who
was a contemporary of Alan Turing a
Bletchley Park very famous method he
came up with a really nice law which
which works pretty well which is treat
others as you would like to be treated
yourself which is a pretty good role for
a robot to follow but not quite even
that doesn't work right you know because
a robot likes me to give it electricity
yeah so it's going to treat other people
with electricity Ritter there's lots of
things very what's one that we don't
want to vice-versa it right and then
hopefully we can get machines to learn
this this is something maybe people
thinking about maybe we can get machines
to observe us and work out what our
values are to work out what we want but
that's again even that's challenging you
know we do lots of things you know we
eat sugary we drink sugary drinks but we
shouldn't drink weed we use drugs that
we shouldn't do we do things that are
that we you know we don't want ourselves
to do but we're just you know morally
too weak to to follow so to our values
are not defined by our actions and so
observing us is not good enough just to
work out what what human values are so
it's a really challenging problem we can
have to solve this problem that
increasingly as we let machines act in
our world well I have two questions one
is how to encounter the technology race
for example in areas where you have
money laundering prevention when
criminals start to use software to stay
below the radar the second question is I
sorry I didn't quite get the first
question
I didn't quite get the first question
how do you avoid the race of Technology
in areas where you want don't want to
have the race like when you have money
laundering anti-money laundering
software trying to detect money
laundering and the criminals start to
use machine learning processes in order
to test what is the radar level how to
stay below the radar more anti money
laundering
I think it's almost impossible to stop
technology races it's almost impossible
to stop such races of course I mean the
the solutions the end of the day is AI
is likely to be part of the cure is not
as part of the problem but you know the
only way that we're going to be able to
defend ourselves against cyber attacks
is by having smarts or software that has
the ability to look at all of all of the
hardware with the response time the only
computers can do so technology is part
of the solutions task part of some
in the case of the technology
technological race for autonomous
weapons the way there is to make it
morally repugnant that's how we've done
it with every other technology that's
why we don't have chemical weapons
because it's morally repugnant to have
chemical weapons and when they get used
in Syria
there's headlines in The New York Times
there's resolutions on the floor of the
UN and that's been enough and the threat
of perhaps being brought into some court
and The Hague some distant point in the
future to stop to a large extent their
use and that's what all we can hope for
example with autonomous weapons is that
we make it morally repugnant that people
aren't prepared to use them the second
question I had was related to autonomous
cars how do you solve the moral hazard
when the car needs to decide which right
is higher to appreciate the one the
produced pedestrian jumping in front of
the car kill the pedestrian or kill the
car driver on my question this might be
solved by judges saying in the
Netherlands the right of the pedestrian
is higher in Germany the judge might
decide the car driver need to be the one
to be saved how can you train the model
this is the classic trolley problem of
course it's worth pointing out there
this is why it's the going to be the
Golden Age of philosophy because the
trolley program has existed for a
hundred years a hundred years since we
had all since we had cars you and I at
any point we're driving down the road
may have to solve the trolley problem
someone jumps in someone walks into the
road we have to make a split-second
decision and we have to make the right
decision if you make the wrong decision
what happens well if you survive the
accident and you made the wrong decision
it was considered that you behaved in a
way that was morally unacceptable you'll
be brought into a court charged with
manslaughter or whatever it is the
challenge we have today is that it's not
that split-second where you get to make
the decision you have to think upfront
when you write the program years in
advance of when that that point happens
so we've been it's
not that we've not had Charlie problems
before it's just that we can having to
think about coding them in advance we
don't know what the answer is we have to
decide it's a society what's acceptable
whether it's going to be the same in
every case this is going to be the same
in Holland as it is in Germany it's
going to be the same in in in Japan as
it is in the United States we don't know
we have as a society to make these
choices and this is why it's going to be
the Golden Age of ethics we're going to
have to think upfront about these
choices that we never had to think up
front in the past interesting enough
this one I think will have one thing to
say before we finish my friends who
writes software for autonomous cars say
there's no routine in the code called
the trolley problem routine the car
doesn't today have enough awareness of
what it's doing to be to have a little
okay now we folks at the subroutine that
ways up the probabilities and branches
according to which one the car has no
awareness that level of meaning to
understand it's facing it's much more
reactive to its environment than that so
it's likely at this point it's an
emergent property of the software it
doesn't remove the ethical question but
there's no software that they write that
says this is the trolley problem soft
subroutine that has to now decide this
decision and we switch the polarity when
we move to Holland okay thank you very
much
[Applause]